we are very grateful to have sueldo she
from Mixpanel who co-founded Mixpanel
almost 10 years ago now and is going to
talk about how to measure your product
which as you heard from Gustav is really
the other side of the coin of growth and
everything that helps you build
something that people truly want and
will use so with that Suhail all right
hello everyone
happy to be here
awesome I thought I would start off by
just kind of like I sometimes try to
gate try to change my presentation a
little bit on the fly depending on the
audience and so I thought I would just
ask like a really quick question just a
quick show of hands um I'm gonna define
like a user's like just someone that
uses your product whether it's a whether
it be to be company paying free doesn't
really matter like they did something in
your product how many people have like
zero users right now okay
cool awesome and then how many people
have a hundred or less well okay you
have greater than zero between 0 1 and
100
okay awesome great and then how many
people have like more than 10,000 okay
awesome all right so we've got it's a
majority of people have zero users right
now
cool awesome great so I'm gonna start
off with just a quick about me
for those who don't haven't heard of
Mixpanel um I started this company
called Mixpanel I think the first line
of code was written in like October 2008
technically I was like 20 years old I
was in my parents house in my bedroom
and and you know 10 years later the
company has about 300 employees we've
raised a bunch of money and we have
about 7,000 paying customers and we're
starting to close in on around 100
million dollars in annual recurring
revenues just to give you a sense of
yeah 2008 to now cool
awesome um if you don't know what mix
phenol is we make pretty graphs like
this we help you measure what people are
doing inside the product so this is like
you know someone inviting a colleague to
their app we might help you like measure
a funnel and see the conversion rate of
people opening your app to like viewing
an article will help you measure
retention I know Gustav went over that a
little bit today and I'm just showing
you this just because like everything
that I talked about today is is
basically is something that you could
probably do in Mixpanel or even any
other tool there are a bunch of tools
that are great to measure these things
but I want you to know that if you
walked out the door and you wanted to
apply any of it you totally could
there's there's like a freemium plan and
we cater very very much to startups
those are all of our early customers so
feel free to do that awesome great so
today what I wanted to dive into was I
thought I would take a top-down approach
to thinking about analytics and metrics
instead of kind of coming at you with
charts and visualizations and numbers
and things like that I thought it would
be better to kind of think about the
problem that you're trying to actually
solve and it's sort of ignore for a
moment that you have to like do complex
analysis and calculations um you will
figure that out it's not hard or you'll
just use tools that will make that a lot
easier for you so that's one thing that
I thought I would do and so I picked
these three things um I tried to think
pretty hard about like what the heck did
I care about when I started a company
like what mattered to me
what was on my mind and I thought well I
think the first thing is just like do
people even understand what I made and
mixed well I had a really hard time with
that in its first 18 months we had to
change a lot of things and most people
do the second thing is okay great
they kind of understand what it is but
do they like find it relatively easy to
use the product on day one and that
that's kind of this never-ending mission
that you'll end up taking when you start
your company and when you ship your
product and then they'll and the last
thing is you know I kind of tried to
pare it down a little bit but I thought
most important thing would be then next
are people coming back and using my
product and I think that you'll find
that like I know Gustaf talked about
this and I'm going to be extremely
repetitive because it's one of the most
important things that early founders
make a mistake with yeah so from there I
thought that I would try to also I
thought that it'd also be helpful for
you to see it kind of broken down in a
formula and so this is the formula and I
think I like to think about things from
first principles right like what are the
things that would cause you to grow and
they're pretty simple right there's just
like people that visit some page or the
app write basic you experience this
every day and then there's like people
that sign up and then of those people
like who did something how many of those
people did something valuable like
watching a video or making a recipe or
you know taking a scooter a scooter ride
and then of the people like how many of
those people end up coming back some
period of time later and then how many
people will like spread that product
like tell a friend share it maybe you
even have a sales team who knows right
and these these five things like
basically equal growth and these are
your lovers and the thing that I wanted
to kind of point out and I want to
stress is that today I'm gonna cover the
basics but I want to kind of implore on
you that the basics are really important
even thousand-person companies get the
basics wrong in fact you'll find that if
you don't get the even these thousand
person companies that get it wrong they
tend to overcomplicate the number of
things that they should actually measure
and track and it's really easy to make
twenty five metrics conceive of them
align them you know divide them ball by
you know give each team five and then
really over complicate something that is
actually quite simple to do when you
over complicate it what happens is is
that companies even large companies have
immediate paralysis even midsize large
companies have this like decision
making problem used to have this funny
phrase at Mixpanel where I used to say
that all data is like contestable you
know you could like see this number go
off into the right and go oh well I
don't know it was like sunny outside and
like and that's why people did it and
people will like have these arguments no
matter what because causation is really
hard to discover and so what I find is
that just picking like three to five
things on Northstar and really
simplifying it will do more good for you
and I know because not only have I
watched thousands of companies make this
mistake at all sizes I have made this
mistake I had a piece of paper that had
like 25 sub metrics and it was nearly
impossible to actually keep track of it
and what and people end up doing is in
reality what people care about is there
are there are metrics that guide the
team and there are metrics that help you
monitor and assess if anything is going
wrong and today we're gonna talk about
things that guide the team okay cool
great so with this formula you should be
able to assess anything going wrong in
the company right if you're if you have
a really confusing landing page it you
should be able to figure that out if
your signup process is too difficult you
should be able to figure that out if
you've a product that people don't
really value you will figure that out
with just that formula it's just that
simple and you can get more complicated
after that right you could say okay
landing page views are down all of a
sudden why who is it by Clemmy look at
that segmented by country maybe
something happened maybe I changed
something in a different country so you
should be able to assess any reason why
you're not growing just starting out
with that and that's why I say starting
simple will last a very long time so
this is what it looks like right linking
those two ideas together you have this
funnel of people going from visits to
you know eventually retaining and
spreading the product and like on each
one of these things you're trying to
basically solve one of these three
problems is it easy to understand is it
easy to get started are people coming
back because they find it valuable and
and then it loops and the funny thing
about this is even if
you're like Airbnb and you're thousands
and thousands of people this like this
process of like optimizing each one of
these steps is never-ending no matter
how you're no matter what scale you're
at there will always be changing
something and you probably have
competition so you'll have no choice so
awesome and then once you are able to
measure those five things and assess
what's wrong
you have your levers and you should be
able to take action and fix any of those
things put a team on it maybe you're
fixing it it was really that simple
awesome so we're gonna start with the
first thing which is is my product easy
to understand in order in order to
illustrate this idea I decided that it
would be somewhat sympathetic because I
could show you like really awesome
landing pages of like great companies or
I could just show you like what it's
like to start out and and I also wanted
to mention that having a really bad
landing page um there's this really
awesome quote that PG used to have in
our batch that I thought I would impart
on you which is that like people
basically just have their mouths like
hovering on the back button and they're
just waiting to say I don't know what
this is confusing back and that's
immediately how most companies are just
like losing most of their um users from
moving on and so just remember that your
enemy is the back button so this is what
mixed panels first front page look like
in 2009 that's not what our logo looks
like anymore this is a design by me
original design by me and and and in all
of its glory if you like actually goalie
read the words there's like tons of
grammatical mistakes because I was
horrible at writing and for some reason
in my mind I thought I know what the
tagline for the company should be
metrics that'll make you drool
I don't I and I guess I think the reason
why was because I thought these graphs
were like so pretty looking compared to
what was out there that I thought like
that would be like the value proposition
of the company and of course is like
totally wrong like you're all laugh I
wish I could have like made this landing
page presented it to you then you don't
laugh at me okay I should change that
thing but I didn't have that I had zero
users at the time you know and I tried
to target you know small startup big
company I didn't know who I was
targeting application developer I like
trying to target everybody like this is
like every mistake that one could make
on a landing page is like right here
right like the signup button at least I
kind of got that right thank you Endora
for teaching me how to optimize buttons
that slide like made it like yellow but
that's about that's about maybe all that
I got right right just maybe they are
roughly the signup button and then you
know after a lot of work a lot of hard
work a lot of iteration a lot of talking
to customers a lot of measurement you
know eventually a couple years later it
kind of turned into this right I like
managed to get like the logo right a
sign-up buttons like ginormous and
yellow and and and what we figured out
though after after a lot of time and a
lot of energy was that we transform for
metrics that'll make you drool to
actions speak louder than pages and and
you'll notice it's like extremely
prominent the reason why was because the
number one question that people that we
would get as a company was that's cool
but like how are you different than
Google Analytics I don't get it right
and so it turned out like this
tagline for us at the front page lasted
like the next five years of the company
and and because it like very much
differentiated us as something where we
would measure engagement we did
something different like Google was
about pageviews we were about like what
people did in your app and that
resonated and then and then from there
again we tried to explain like what
various we try to urge people to go down
the website and like look at different
features and see if those things were
valuable we tried to be benefits
oriented and the copy tried to show
customers and case studies who maybe
found it valuable
we've probably made like four changes
after this but I thought I'd present
this one just because it was the one
that maybe lasted like the the copy and
the general essence of what we did
instead we did what we said we did kind
of stayed the same
largely but lots of design changes so um
the real question is you know great so
like how do I measure how did you
measure whether people really understood
whether they understood what you were
doing and so I think there's like one
tried and trued number and it's like
very simple it's just did people even
bother to sign up bothering to sign up
doesn't mean that they're gonna use your
products that's a whole different matter
bothering to sign up is like I don't
know I'm kind of interested I'll kick
the tires this seems kind of interesting
and cool to me
and that'll tell you a lot about whether
what you're doing is even something
valuable for people the second thing
that you can try these are just ideas
trying to find the ratio of people that
are going from just like hitting your
page right and then there's and then
doing any kind of thing after that so
instead of aka instead of hitting the
back button right like did they click on
segmentation or funnels or attention in
that case right did they bother to do
that I know there are a lot of b2b
companies um these days actually one
quick question how many people are
making like a b2b company yeah great so
that's about half the room so I thought
I'd give a b2b slant one thing that I
discover was that people a lot of your
users will click on a pricing page link
at the top it's like second or third
like most clicked-on link if your b2b
company I think generally speaking I
Jenna I think you know this is totally
contestable but I find that like people
clicking on your pricing page is like
actually a pretty decent indicator of
like okay cool you have something kind
of valuable okay how much and so even
something like that I think can tell you
a lot and then if you're in consumer the
benefit of being in consumer is that you
generally have usually will have like
hundreds or thousands of users such that
you could actually go do an a/b test
whereas in b2b it's a lot harder to
achieve that and so I really I think
Gustav is absolutely right that you
should try
to conduct as many experimentation
experiments as you can and really a B
test your copywriting and find out like
what resonates with people but these are
all things that you can do to basically
figure out hmm
is this easy cool so the second the
second one is well is it easy to get
started with my product and the thing
about this is like a lot of people the
thing about about these first two things
is that if you don't make the first step
easy if it's easy to understand a lot of
people put so much energy when we're
trying to build a company we try to
think about like all the cool features
and things that we could make that'll be
really valuable for customers the
problem with that is like if you don't
even get step one right you don't even
have a chance at any of the subsequent
steps so when we think about like is it
easy to get started with my product you
know forgot about password is kind of a
useless feature if you have like a very
small percentage of people that are
basically like not even bothering to get
started in fact I remember there was a
YC company called Zen tur which turned
into like Google slides and I remember a
Robby Walker during one of our one of
one of our Tuesday dinners said that
they had they didn't even implement the
save button for like their online
PowerPoint because they knew that none
of their users would ever asked like hey
can I save this
they just even bother to do it because
they wanted to see what anyone even use
the PowerPoint presentation product it
was like that was in that one day and
part of that on me I was kind of like
wow that's crazy and for a like I don't
know maybe like 18 months of Mixpanel we
didn't even have forgot about password
because we were just so ruthlessly
trying to prioritize like things that
really would really matter to customers
and it turned out we didn't get very
many requests anyway so this is really
important and here's an example of like
easy to use something you use every
single day
that is literally one-step you just go
to google you type it in and you
immediately get to use the product
there's no signup there's no CAPTCHAs
there's none of that right a more
complex example life is like Airbnb who
might have like you know ten steps or
something like that we worked with air
me for a while helping them optimize
initial user experience and you know
even though Airbnb probably has like 11
pages of you know like you have to go to
Airbnb and then you have to fill out
this form and then you get taken to the
results and then you click on those
results and then you you know you click
on many different results because you're
trying to price compare and you're going
through this very complex checkout
process so they're actually many steps
to booking something online but Airbnb
had to kind of figure out like how do we
a describe what we're doing what we
offer what's useful for the world and be
how do we help people get started as
quickly as easily as possible and like
this is Airbnb calm right now and it's
you know they have this very simple like
book unique homes and experiences you
fill out these very basic things and you
hit search and that's it that's their
getting started experience it's not
their entire flow but it's the first way
to get started and they even try to like
kind of impute something like what you
might what you might be able to find
something imaginative on Airbnb but the
thing is is that this seems simple right
this seems like something that you could
just like easily make it doesn't take
how hard is that right we can do that
with Twitter bootstrap in no time the
problem the thing that's really hard is
like figuring out that that's the right
thing that's really hard that takes like
they probably change that you know 50
times before they figure it out like
this is the right current optimal thing
at this stage for the company and so it
takes a lot of work in and you have to
grind very hard to get to this at this
point so question is like okay great so
how do you how would you measure
something like that well I think the
really simple answer is a funnel
how many people go from a landing page
to signing up to doing that valuable
thing like watching a video doing an
Airbnb space who had been just doing a
search just one search at least once you
get past that measuring your funnel for
the entire initial user experience
there's like weird things we're like
there's actually situations in games
games can have like 20 steps and I've
noted and I've seen hundreds of gaming
companies funnels
and even though they might have like 20
or 30 steps sometimes you can they
actually convert very highly like they
might get like 8090 percent conversion
rate through all those 20 steps just the
first two are like actually the ones
that have the greatest drop-off and then
the last thing is just like actually
speed this is one that I think a lot of
people don't actually do they're just
like how fast how fast can someone just
get started and that will tell you a lot
about how complicated your experience is
sometimes slow is okay it depends on the
business but speed is really important
does it take them like five minutes to
get something figured out or does it
take a minute in mixed panels case we
cared a lot about like we had a
complicated flow because you not only
did you have to sign up but you have to
be a little to write code just really
complicated and that was the one
downside we weren't really sure where
people with Google Analytics you just
copy and paste the JavaScript with mixed
family had to like actually go and track
a line of code and so we had this
question our mind was that easy enough
and so speed became really important to
us how fast can someone do that and I
wanted to give you a couple tips and
tricks things that I have seen that
companies do that are generally like not
great number one you're a start-up you
don't have lots of fraud problems you
don't have you probably don't have a lot
of people spamming your service you
probably don't have a lot of like fake
actors in the system trying to sign up
so if you don't have those problems
don't optimize for them until you do and
I just want you to know that II
generally email and text confirmations
have an enormous drop-off like I'm
talking like you get of the hundred
percent of the people that come like
only thirty percent will like basically
go on and like click on those email
confirmations or forty percent you spend
a lot of time trying to optimize that
and then TV make matters even worse like
you have to hope to god that it isn't go
to spam like it's this really horrendous
experience so just be really careful
you'll lose a lot of users that way it's
really important to iterate on your
initial user experience that will be a
never-ending process you will do this
forever even as the press especially as
the product
it becomes really critical to like have
someone on it so at least one
responsible person just thinking about
that all the time and then the last
thing is is not every company not every
product is capable of doing this but to
the extent that you can just let users
into the product it's always better to
do that in mixed fennels case it wasn't
possible because like we needed to get
your data so you have to sign up but we
experimented with like what if someone
just copied and pasted the JavaScript
but they didn't sign up and we just
collected their data and then after that
we like asked them to sign up we did
experiments like that so to the extent
that you can achieve achieve this that's
awesome and good examples of this are
actually like Airbnb and Google where
you just just try it but there are
always exceptions to these rules for
example like Pinterest makes you sign up
and they didn't used to but they do now
they're good reasons for that and then
and then the last one definitely not
least are people coming back to me this
is probably one of the metrics that is
greatly ignored by most startups and
it's often the reason why I've seen
companies even with millions of users
actually dive I've seen probably 15
different companies that grew virally
and then just died the company died and
I want to demonstrate this in a graph I
called this the shark fin effect and the
reason why I call it the shark fin
effect is because well one was because
Mixpanel in in Mixpanel the default line
color for your first like data point is
like blue and so it always to me it
always looked like a fin like in the
water and it looked a lot like this and
what happens is you fought you like
you're slaving away and you find a way
to go viral right maybe you're going
super viral on Facebook or on some or
Instagram or something and you're like
wow I have struck gold I'm acquiring
tons of users my life is awesome
I'm going to be a billionaire is great
right and the problem with this is is
that if it happens too early but you
didn't quite think about if you quite
think quite thing
about retention and becomes really
problematic and Yulin and this hurts
companies so basically what happens is
the app goes viral and then eventually
the rate at which you're losing users
becomes so it becomes high enough that
you can't acquire the new ones
and it turns out that like even though
we like to try to be extremely rational
people it's really hard because like
when the apps going viral you're just
like oh my god I need to like just take
advantage of this moment because what if
I don't get in what if my competitor
finds it so I'm just gonna optimize
optimize optimize but it turns out that
it ends up not being very valuable
because if you're just losing all the
users it's really really hard to
reactivate if you talk to people that
have ever done like a reactivation
campaign your activation campaigns
generally don't go very well you usually
just like lose those users until they
decide that maybe they want to give the
product a second chance so it's not like
like your response is like when this
happens a lot of people's response is
like oh we lost the users because our
app wasn't valuable let's just email
them again and see if they'll come back
and like that's usually not a great idea
so it can be really it's really
important to really think through
retention and you really don't want to
be like this guy the shark fin effect is
really really bad in fact LivingSocial
is a great example a lot of people don't
know that like LivingSocial was
basically this app that was on facebook
that had nothing to do with like like
the Groupon deal cutting thing and they
went super viral on I can't exactly
can't remember exactly what the product
was um and LivingSocial literally had to
pivot the entire company to basically
competing with Groupon because the app
wasn't very retentive um in those days
so there's some pretty basic ways to
measure that people are coming back
the most obvious one that I hope most
people know is that there's just new
users so making sure that you're
tracking whether a brand new user
someone who just signed up what
percentage of those users will come back
like a week later or thirty days later
it's really important to track a longer
period of time because a week later is
just not a harsh enough metric and it's
important to see how fast you'll end up
losing users because you'll have to
figure out a way to read to Rhian gate
to find new ones and that becomes really
really hard at some point if the number
of users you have you
becomes starts to become quite high and
then the second one is is just daily
active users there might be people that
disagree with this I don't think they're
too many but I now think that monthly
active users has become like the new BS
metric that's like very similar to like
just like a number of registered users
like number of registered users like a
very silly metric I remember seven or
eight years ago I think like I want to
say it was like LinkedIn came out and
said we have 200 million registered
users there's like who cares how many
people are using LinkedIn and I now
start starting to think that like Mau is
like becoming quite close to that now
daily active users is really hard to
maintain I mean how many products do you
use every single day like if you just
look at your phone and you go through
all of the possible apps like how many
of those do you actually use every
single day so I think it's a really
harsh metric and we actually found at
Mixpanel so even if you're a b2b company
and you might think well I don't know
I'm selling to businesses so like kind
of really maintain like a daily active
users especially on Saturday and Sunday
and we actually found that there's like
a really really strong correlation with
daily use and rate of churn like rate of
like people like stop not no longer
paying for the product and it didn't
take very many users it was like one
point you know for daily actives would
like reduce churn to like a dollar turn
by like to like I don't know like some
10 percent is incredible and so I really
stress measuring a da you and then the
last thing is a b2b slant again is
something that I think a lot of b2b
companies make an early mistake with
it's actually not just a b2b company
it's actually companies that do
subscription so I don't know if they're
any companies that would ever think that
they may offer a subscription of any
sort you know like if you're a
meditation app or something like that um
and it's just dollar its monthly dollar
turns if you're charging your customers
monthly many businesses charge annually
but usually most startups start with
monthly because an annual commitment
sometimes can be hard for early adopters
is just measuring revenue churn I want
to give you I'm gonna give you a slight
story
if you have if you have if if you have
revenue churn and your revenue churn is
say 7% per month right you might think
awesome
I'm keeping 93 percent of these dollars
every single month this is awesome
I'm doing really really really well the
problem is is it's seven percent monthly
churn and if you extrapolate that out
over 12 months it's actually you're
actually losing fifty fifty eight
percent of your revenue in a year it's
really harsh and a lot of people like
for some reason this like this thing is
like not mathematically intuitive to
most people I don't know why it wasn't
even mathematically intuitive to me
early on and if you think about it like
you're spending all of this energy with
marketing and improving the landing page
and improving the getting starting flow
and you're doing all of that and if you
don't have retention if you're losing
that seven percent every single month
you have to somehow make up for that
fifty eight percent that you lost going
into the new year and if you start
thinking about you're like wow we're
making a million dollars and we're
losing five hundred and eighty thousand
dollars and we're starting the year like
that
you now you have to do that and grow on
top of that and once your base of
revenue gets really high it becomes
really hard to keep up and you kind of
have this like really long arc of like a
shark fin effect basically so it's
really important to look at your monthly
churn and this will be the single cause
of like death but the problem is it's
like the worst kind of death it's like
death that occurs it's really like it's
really flat growth but it occurs like
eventually in like four or five years if
you're able to acquire users and I
mentioned this not only because you know
it talked to some founders about this
but this is also something that like
really hurt us in the early stages of
Mixpanel and we really had to figure out
a way to fix this and there's all kinds
of ways you can use product you can use
pricing there's all kinds of ways to
experiment with this but this thing
probably gave me the greatest number of
nightmares and lack of sleep I think
ever so I really want to stress that on
all b2b companies here really think
through this number and think about like
almost graph like okay what would our
rate of growth be if churn stayed
constant
really important cool I wanted to go
over two things one I recognize that
there a lot of people here that have
zero users so they're like what the hell
do I measure so what if I have less than
50 users well the truth is I couldn't
really think of a better idea than just
basically you just have to talk to your
users and I thought I'd give you a mini
story about at least that makes the
panel what we did when we had like no
users and I had that page that just said
metrics you'll drool over one trick that
I used is that I had like maybe 10 or 11
or 12 customers and honestly I just I
just put all of them on I am like on
gchat or something I don't know what the
kids use these days maybe like what's
that but but but I honestly just like
would just badger them on like whatsapp
or you know gchat or whatever and then
just ask them and I remember one time we
were trying to redesign our funnel UI
and we used to have a vertical funnel
but we had a competitor that has a
horizontal funnel and it seemed like
that was a better idea it seemed like
that was more intuitive for customers
and so I didn't really know how to like
get the data cuz like how was I really
gonna find out whether they liked one of
those two you eyes and I didn't have the
it was just me and a co-founder so like
how the heck were we gonna like do an
a/b test on that feature there's no real
way to realistic way to do that and so
all I did was I just made like a really
crappy version of the UI that I thought
would be better the horizontal version
of a funnel I was a kind of greyscale
and I mean like a really beautiful
colorful version of like the vertical
one which was kind of our control and
then I just asked like eleven people
which one's better and I want to I want
to impress this thing because Gustav
mentioned that it's the it's the Delta
it's the difference that matters an a/b
test not that this is like a true
perfect AV test but like I asked eleven
people and I am got feedback in a day
and ten out of the eleven said
horizontal funnels and then we just made
it and we built it and we never looked
back and it was totally the right
decision in retrospect so I don't think
there's any way that you can kind of
skirt by talking to customers but here's
the bet here's the benefit of talking to
customers even though it feels maybe
it's more tedious than looking at a
graph you are going to get way more info
and depth from talking to customers then
you ever will
looking at a data point in a graph no
matter how much you slice and dice and
segment the data no matter how
mathematical you are about it you will
never get as much information and into
in building your own intuition than just
talking to customers and it's really
critical that you do it and the one
thing that I wish I had done back then
was I just wrote I wish I just wrote it
down I wish I wrote down tons of the
feedback because I think that it would
have helped my co-founder would have
helped employees in the company down the
road really go on the journey make them
feel like they went on the journey with
me rather than having our roles kind of
feeling like they were so split up and
then the last thing that I thought I
would bring up is is to impart what I
kind of said at the beginning which is
that I think I think that one of the
biggest mistakes that people make with
analytics is being really
overcomplicated thinking that they need
to be super sophisticated thinking that
they need to track all kinds of crazy
cohorts and they need to have like a
dashboard with like 30 you know panes on
it that all like loads you have like
Mission Control I don't think that is
necessary I had that it didn't work it
was really hard to run the company that
way and in what also happens is is that
when you build your team it will be
really hard you will be confusing for
your team of those 30 panes like which
one do I need to care about and I think
that it's we need things that are humans
just need to simplify things so I'd pick
one Northstar metric and I think in a
Northstar metric I would choose in this
case is like what is a number that
you're willing to bet the company on
right like if that number goes south you
deserve to die
if that number goes up you will like you
will have like made a huge dent in the
universe like what is that what is that
metric and I'm not saying you need to
choose that metric forever but choose it
for six months choose it commit some
time to it if you find out that it's
actually like the wrong metric which it
will be probably the first time you
choose is usually your metrics are wrong
and then you can change it but commit
again to for another six months but
choose that one number and then like if
what you have to do at the beginning is
basically just like print it out and
put it all around the office do it
because people will start to be
maniacally focused on it they'll show up
to meetings and go yeah but that number
is like down what are we gonna do and
where you can get really complex is
discovering why that number is down or
why it's going up that's when you can
get really sophisticated that's when you
can slice and dice it and figure out
what the retention is and things like
that and measure it over a funnel but
keep things really simple and then the
second thing is like don't boil the
ocean like pick three to five other
things I think less is more and just
stay there telling even large companies
most large companies don't do this and
it usually is very discombobulating for
them for the workforce it's totally fine
to have numbers that you wish to monitor
but don't focus on them awesome I think
that's it and then for the people that
were like slightly bored because I went
over the basics I thought I would help
you out by just kind of having some
advanced topics for later that you could
read about really these are things that
like I found really useful my favorite
one is this one the next feature fallacy
by Andrew Chen and it's just this idea
that we always think that like the next
thing that we make will be the thing
that will change the trajectory of the
company a kie like the next features
right around the corner and we're gonna
be huge and I would really recommend
that you read that article it's really
awesome one of my my favorite one so for
advanced stuff these are just people
worth following reading about and can
give you more ideas than what I've given
you today awesome thank you
Jeff Kuhn a cool all right
yeah I want to be fair I don't be like
if like every speaker like choose them
in the front yeah yeah so that's the
problem with that is that um it's soo
it's so yeah oh yes I think someone
asked what are like good benchmarks for
like those given those five steps
visiting signing up you know using the
product what would be good conversion
rates for any one of those steps and the
the chart part with benchmarks like that
is that it's so dependent on the
business you know in b2b like going from
like a visit to a sign up like I think I
got like a four to five percent
conversion rate is pretty good I think I
like swap notes with Stewart at slack
because we kind of had similar landing
pages I think I asked him you know what
was your conversion rate at slack and I
think we both ended up being somewhere
around like four to five percent from
visit to sign up but but that said like
I don't know what that would be for you
know something like Airbnb where it's
like getting to a landing page and then
you know searching for your first place
that you would want a book so I think
it's really dependent I know that I know
that Mixpanel published it on its blog
publishes lots of benchmarks so I know
that I know the marketing team there
that does that and they like publish all
kinds of benchmarks for like what's what
should your retention be if your gaming
company if you're an e-commerce company
if you're a b2b company things like that
social company a video company things
like that so I think that you could
probably go there and find various
benchmarks reports but it's really
depending on the business yeah
[Music]
so when you're going through the signup
process how do you see numbers vary if
you're large like creative accountant a
and password doing all that kind of
setup versus a single like button login
with like cool guy how does that like
transfer do more people to sign up if
they have that like super click option
do you see where they will drop off
because they have to use one of those so
yeah are you I think the question is um
if what what is what converts better
like those like social buttons where you
can just like quickly authenticate like
Facebook Connect versus just like
standard signup is that right yeah like
all of these questions they require like
a lot of specificity because it's
actually like really unclear and
actually and in that case actually don't
know I truly don't know and so I think
the way to answer this question is to
find friends in tangential industries
that like don't compete with you but
basically do that and then just be like
hey what did what have you what is your
conversion rate have you tried something
I I don't actually think a lot of those
numbers are like secrets in reality
right unless you I mean you can't go to
your competitor and ask that but like
most of these things are not like super
duper secret type stuff and like you
know they could either give you the
information and save you you know the
six months or the or they'll just like
say or you try it out but it's it's just
it's sort of strange to keep it a secret
so I would rather give you ways that you
can discover that I would just ask
friends that have like have a startup or
even if they work at a big company
sometimes they're willing to share it
yeah so question is Airbnb ease landing
page was super simple and how do you
balance like I mean what if a lot of
people just know about Airbnb and then
just know what to use Airbnb for and
then that's why they can keep it kind of
simple versus like having something more
complex a good example of this is like
Craigslist is crazy
if you go to like the front page of
Craigslist it's like absolutely nuts
it's in like even Amazon if you go to
amazon.com right like even though Amazon
has like huge brand recognition you go
to amazon.com and it's like whoa there's
like million things going on at once
right so how have these companies found
the balance how have they found how to
deal with this complexity and and the
truth is is that I find that it's it's
important to have like a guiding
principle like what is it that you're
trying to actually optimize for right if
in the case of YouTube
let's take YouTube as a good example
right YouTube could just like be like
Google they just like what do you want
to look what do you want to watch right
they could do that but they don't and so
I think that the question really is is
like what is YouTube
what is the team at YouTube trying to
optimize for are they just trying to get
you to like watch a video are the is
Airbnb just trying to get you to search
for any kind of hotel or a hotel but
Airbnb and so I think that like the team
has to develop first a hypothesis of
like what matter what do we think
matters and then from there it's
important to experiment and try to
figure that out it turns out like it's
it's not - again it's about the Delta of
like what people will actually gravitate
more towards like if you make a really
simple experience but like people are
like really confused
because they don't even bother to do it
or you or you ask them then you kind of
have like new information and then I
think the key is to find the minimum
number of things you need to add to get
someone started and you know and I think
I don't think there's anything you know
I'm sure Amazon has tested that front
page like crazy and they found that it's
like quite optimal yeah
[Music]
the can it depends on the product I'll
give you I'll give you an example in
mixed panels case oh sorry the case yeah
the question was our video are like one
to two minute video tutorials effective
there yeah so I think that it's it's
complex we did a video tutorial video
and our flow for example and you know
like I would say that I would say that
like a lot of people didn't watch it
truthfully and inner and this is what I
mean by experimentation like a lot of
people didn't watch that video Vittorio
me actually I think eliminated it you
know the first three steps but what we
did find was this interesting thing that
occurred as a result of looking and
measuring things which was that um well
we have a feature in mix panel where you
can like see every action that a user
takes and so I would literally just like
go to every user and then just like
watch like a creepy person just like
sort of watching like everything that
like someone would do in the product and
eventually when you do that like when
you do like hundreds of those and you've
just watched hundreds of those you start
to develop some sense of like okay you
what you develop is a an idea a
hypothesis and all of these things like
all of these things require art and
science and I think that companies that
take it too far they like take take it
too far to science end up getting it
wrong they end up optimizing for like
weird things like you could always make
a button more yellow and bigger and like
but that doesn't meet that doesn't make
users happy eventually and so anyway to
answer your question what I found was
that lots of people were just clicking
randomly on like all the myth side menu
options and my hypothesis was well they
had an integrated mix panel yet so
there's nothing to look at so what the
heck were you doing just like clicking
on like funnels and retention like why
would you do that and my hypothesis was
they were just curious like what the
product did what is it that they did and
so we did this a B test where we like
had a control with like nothing you know
just the regular you know clicking
around seeing like some image and then
we had another one that had like videos
and then we tried to see like what
caused people to like do their
integration their first integration
what was the conversion rate and it
turned out like the video like super one
actually we didn't even a more simple
test than that I think we just emailed
people a video and said watch this video
super basic didn't even bother to
implement it on the website and had an
amazing conversion rate and then we
decided to add videos all to all those
tabs where there wouldn't have been
anything anyway and so that's why I want
to say like I want to stress this it
really depends and what matters is that
you run the experiment to develop a
hypothesis ie the art not the science
and then measure it which is the science
to find out whether the thing that you
thought of was in fact right the a
percent loss in revenue over a year yeah
so what these are slightly two different
things one is one is like user retention
and then one is like dollar churn and so
in the case of dollar turn like the
reason I bring up dollar turn is that
even like you could totally have a
company where nobody uses the product
and the company continues to keep paying
for it right but I find that like most
companies are like pretty incentivized
to cut their spending and employees or
incentivize because they lose it in
their budget and so with respect to
dollar turn you can have lot in a b2b
company for example you can have a lot
of use you can have you can have even
one user using the product but the
company could continue to you continue
to spend money on it and like you might
see like a forty percent retention rate
like might be okay right as long as the
company is like continuing to spend but
losing 40 percent of your dollars in a
year is really hard and not good
retention so make sense so those things
are not exactly linked they're not
directly linked yeah yeah
yeah like to give you to give you kind
of a benchmark like a chat app that's
like often used a lot we'll have like 60
70 percent retention like those are some
of the most retentive things like
something like slack would probably have
like eighty percent retention it's kind
of like unbelievable whereas um you know
like a product like mix panel when we
first started out like the first year I
think we had like 30 40 percent you know
retention and that's not that great but
who's their first few years yeah yeah so
a question is are these metrics can they
be used for hardware startup yeah I
don't I don't see any reason why we
worked with jawbone for a long time and
we work with Fitbit and most hardware
does your cart hardware company have a
software component to it okay so it's a
hardware company with subscription model
yeah yeah absolutely
it may be more challenging as a hardware
company to track but it's like sometimes
but it's totally doable most hardware is
like connected to the internet somehow
so I don't see any reason why like a lot
of the scooter companies for example
they're like all connected to hardware
and they have a software component so
there's really no difference
yeah so question is the first page was
like trying to target like various kinds
of sizes of companies and then like the
second landing page of Mixpanel like in
2012 basically didn't kind of disposed
of that and it had something very
different it was marketing like features
and stuff and how do you figure out like
what to do basically from that point to
the next point yeah so I think that the
basic gist is that so you can clearly
see like I had no idea who our customers
were and then after like a few years you
just you talk to users you ask them like
what size of company they are if they
sign up if you want to we didn't do that
but we just spent a lot of time we just
it was so obvious that like everyone
that was signing up for make spell at
that time was a start-up so for a small
in our in our case would be we call that
a small business
I think like took like maybe no longer
than six months to figure out that we
were not gonna sign up a large company
yeah we just didn't have the product it
just wasn't there we hadn't worked on it
long enough so the only people that were
willing to basically try it were
companies that could take the risk to
try it and most of those companies
didn't have anything anyway so it was
even easier is it easier to target
companies that had nothing and and had
had we're willing to bear risk and then
most of the time I would always employ
this trick where I would just I would
charge the money for it and then if they
said no I would just give it to them for
free because the feedback was more
important but I always wanted to see if
they would pay for it and so the only
people that are willing to do that are
also small businesses turns out so if
for us it was just like it kind of like
hit us it slapped us in the face it
wasn't like this hard thing to figure
out yeah yeah so we did it to be clear
we weren't necessarily building things
to bring new users on oh sorry the
question is you guys built forgot about
you didn't you just you decided to not
build forgot about password how do you
know when to build quality of life
features versus features that just
acquire new users yeah so I think that
we didn't we didn't we wasn't so much
that we only built features to acquire
new users we built features to acquire
new users and to keep existing users so
we were very focused on like parts of
the product that would actually make a
difference right that would be clearly
differentiating compared to all of the
other Possible's possible options out
there and like one of the things that's
like not different is whether you have
forgot about password right that was
like in the bucket of things that like
maybe don't matter and so I think the
question is like really like when does
it become a problem enough for you that
it's worth building right like if you if
you're finding that like it turns out
that that the number of requests that
you're getting for forgot about password
is like increasing and then manually
doing this process it's like annoying
then
start then you should just build that
feature because you know that if you
don't build a feature they can't login
then you can't retain them and then you
lose them so it becomes this like
flywheel effect where like the only way
to retain them is to do that and in fact
even though Mixpanel didn't build forgot
about password for like maybe you know
12 to 18 months we went eventually we
found that people like people would try
like multiple times I was looking at
that stream of every action that a user
would take I found that like people were
like going to the login screen like five
times and I was just so confused it's
like why are they going to the login
screen five times I was like oh I think
it's because they can't login like some
people don't even hit forgot about past
well just like try try try and I'm sure
you've all done this like with a bank or
something like I'll just do it tomorrow
you know you don't even bother right and
so it turns out that even that happens
and so we went so far even though we
didn't do that I like to think that like
we really made up for this later on we
went so far as to like we found this
like clever trick that Facebook used
which was that when you failed to log in
to Mixpanel like three times on your
third time we just send you an email
that says you know we just sent you an
email just go to your email click the
button you'll log in right now don't
worry about forgetting it don't worry
about changing your password just like
login and it turned out that like that
had this like great retentive effect
because we were really focused on
retention at that time yeah
okay couple more questions yeah how do
you gauge product market fit how do you
measure product market fit so I think
there's a lot of people that probably
have already will talk about or have
already talked about like you know
people will say very and I think they're
there all right so I'll give you a kind
of I'll give you a quantitative slant
versus like a qualitative slant some
qualitative slants or things like when
people are willing to spread you to
their friends that kind of thing the
quantitative version of this is really
just measuring your your attention like
how many people it's really measuring
like da you it's really measuring the
percentage of people that come back a
week later or 30 days later it's the
number of people that like become almost
like they like need your product or they
like feel like life would be a lot worse
and I think that you can you can totally
measure that by how they use it and so I
think the quantitative measurement is
basically finding like some benchmark
some sense that for your industry maybe
that's like thirty percent and just
remember like that benchmark is probably
like average and your desires to
basically be above average and so if you
can like significantly beat that
benchmark then I think that you've like
really you've you've done better than
probably product market fit I think
that's one thing I think another thing
is like you can try to measure like
overall like
repetitive use like frequent use in a
day so like you can make pretty harsh
metrics you can be like for example with
da you you could say I don't want it to
just be daily active user like they did
one thing I want it to be that user has
to have watched five videos and then and
then then and only then or do they count
as a daily active users you can be
particularly harsh about that metric
right someone coming and like just see
that's why I say ma use kind of a BS
metric now because you could come and
watch one video and then never come back
again
and you that count and that's not like a
very healthy business so I think that
find ways to be harsh about your North
Star and I think that you'll find that
that you'll find that you reach the park
market fit yeah yeah I think with
Mixpanel it was like 30 40 percent
retention was
really really horrendous and we totally
didn't have product market fit yet it's
like a Peter teal question what's one
piece of conventional wisdom that you
think is generally wrong about startups
in general gosh that's a hard last
question it's like everything else is
like fine um gosh I think I don't know
I'm not I I need to think about it but I
think that one thing that has like
become pretty clear to me is that I
think I think after having done Mixpanel
for about a decade I kind of figured out
that I tried to impart it on you in in
in the in the talk today which is just
that it's it's much better to just like
I think that we tend to complicate
things as humans and we don't we tend
and that comes that comes through and
like everything for example like we we
tend to have we tend to like make a
version one of a product and then we get
to like version two and we're like okay
we're done we like we did it we solve
the problem and then like often a
founder will like kind of get distracted
and then go and like work on the next
product on the next thing and they
haven't yet figured out like their
retention is probably not great or
they're operating at negative margins or
like all these things that same thing
even happens with numbers like we pick
our three metrics then we continue to
get more complex as a business and then
we add the next 20 things and we all we
do all of these things to like in in
hopes of like feeling like we control
the situation better and I just think
that those are all like distractions and
mistakes and I think it's really hard
for the average founder to actually just
be focused on something boring we tend
to have like a TD or something and like
we just just I decide to get very easily
distracted and I think it's hard to do
something do the same thing for four or
five years
because we don't like feel challenged
anymore and I think that that's a huge
mistake that founders often make and I
don't know that anyone say oh that's
that's that's like totally wrong Suhail
but for whatever reason like every
founder repeats it so there must be
something I don't know something there
must be some kind of wisdom that we all
think this is like the right thing and I
made those mistakes I made new products
that I shouldn't have I met too many
things over optimized things that didn't
need to be optimized so yeah that's
really it cool thanks
[Applause]
you